a quiet Monday morning in the capital
Kiev and then this
not an isolated strike this was one of
multiple missile salvos launched at the
city
others hit the chefchenko district which
includes the historic old town as well
as government offices a busy
intersection in front of the main
building of Kiev University it was rush
hour and the people driving to work were
caught in The Inferno this was the park
nearby
Kiev wasn't the only city targeted from
Levy in the west to kharkiv in the north
to nepro and the center and several more
besides Russia's President Vladimir
Putin was exacting his revenge for an
explosion that damaged the Kirch Bridge
linking Crimea and the Russian Mainland
and other so-called Terror attacks
Ukraine's president
urged people to be resilient
they have two Targets energy facilities
throughout the country and the second is
people such a Time such goals were
chosen to cause as much damage as
possible but we are ukrainians we help
each other we believe in ourselves we
restore everything that is destroyed
Ukraine is certainly quick to do that as
soon as the all clear was given the
cleanup started kiev's mayor came to see
the damage
what Russians did is genocide of Ukraine
population they need Ukraine without
ukrainians and we have a lot of numbers
people who died today civilians and
civilian infrastructure kept looking
great peaceful City
considering the place is hit it's
remarkable the death toll wasn't much
higher
around this huge crater are the Twisted
Metal remnants of what presumably was
the missile now Vladimir Putin says that
this was a response to a terrorist
attack well look at where this missile
struck there's a playground just over
there ukrainians have no doubt who the
real terrorist is
it had been months since the last
airstrikes on Kiev people stopped
responding to the air Sirens thinking
the danger had passed but this is the
biggest missile Onslaught since the
war's early days
Defiance is mixed with fear again we
must be more patient and care about
ourselves and our close people
would it save us would it save us when
he drops a nuclear bomb on us I think we
have to win that's what I think
as if On Cue another air raid warning
and this time people ran
Rory challenge altazira Kiev